[Music]
hi and welcome to episode 203 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast I
am John fells and I'm here with my
colleague aza
hey Asha has been pretty good how are
you doing John pretty good the weather's
turning a little cold here in New York
so I am currently bundled up in very
thick sweater and a wool cap I have to
admit I'm a little jealous it's not
quite cold enough here yet so what are
we gonna be talking about this week John
this week we're gonna be talking to
Donna Molly area about cloud run for
anthos Donna's very very passionate
about cloud run and it's going to be
very interesting to hear all the cool
things that we can do with clown run as
well as the differences between cloud
run for gke and those and that's it yes
yeah and I think looking at our notes
here that you're gonna have a question
about open batch which is the project
that you've been diving into the last
couple weeks yeah that question of the
week is going to be pretty much about
how to write a matchmaking function and
open match and that's gonna be very
helpful because we've just improved the
developer experience for open match so
we're really hoping that people will
take a deep dive and have some fun with
it cool but first my favorite part cool
thing of the week
[Applause]
what's your first cool thing John autumn
Mel has been brought to Kaggle which is
great and they've had like a milestone
at 3.5 million data scientists using and
learning about Donna memo so if you
don't know what Cabul is it's an online
community for like data scientists and
machine learners and you get to look at
datasets and you can publish your own
and it also is a learning platform so if
you're very interested in learning about
any type of machine learning concepts or
anything and if you want to just you
know play with some datasets
take a good look and in you know add to
those numbers that sounds so cool I love
Kegel and all the cool data sets they
have and how they make machine learning
and data science slightly more
approachable because it's kind of
terrifying if it's not your background
right my first school things I have to
cool things my first cool thing over the
week is I was Dorking around this
morning looking at blogs and trying to
figure out what things on my task list
have fallen off the bottom and I
remembered not Jesus the TCP podcast
actually has a page on the website dev
tio the link is going to be in the show
notes but it's divino slash TCP podcast
that what particular website content
aggregator whatever you want to call it
has a special type for podcast episodes
and I have set that up and I had
forgotten that I had done that so it's
there it's super cool if you prefer that
platform you can come leave us comments
and such there that's awesome and to
wrap up my cool things of the week
scripting and store procedures have
finally gone beta in a query so which is
crying because if you're used to you
know writing really complex tasks and
bigquery you know with scripting you can
have a little bit more control flow and
execution flow with the use of like if
statements while statements and even
variables so like you can store these
scripts as procedures which would be
kind of great so if you want a little
bit more control and a little bit more
ease get that look awesome
and my last cool thing of the week my
second cool thing of the week is
scaffold is now GA I thought that on the
cloud platform blog and scaffold this is
awesome tool that folks are using to
help simplify working with kubernetes
because paper notices a lot of moving
parts help simplify containerization and
yeah it's GA I'm so excited I don't like
using beta products I like using GA
practice I'm super happy but it's now GA
that's awesome let's go into our
interview with Donna and see what she
has to say about cloud run for anthos
[Music]
hi you know in this episode of the
pockets we're joined by Donna Molly airy
a fellow Googler who currently works on
G K and cloud run so Donna Q tell us a
little bit about yourself and what you
do
yeah I'm the product manager for cloud
run for anthos and I'm here to talk
about cloud run I've worked in the
service space for a few years I worked
at the Seattle startup plumie which
builds tools for deploying modern cloud
applications I worked on Azure functions
I used to do a lot of stuff in
programming languages so I've been in
the developer tool space for a while
awesome so you mentioned that you work
on cloud run and those can you tell us a
little bit about that so cotton is a
really interesting product because it
offers server less containers and it
comes in two flavors there so a fully
managed version which is the one that's
suitable for most users and essentially
you run on Google's compute so Google
becomes your operations manager
essentially there's also a version
called cloud run for anthos if you
already have a kubernetes cluster and
you want to take on more of those
operations responsibilities
so really clobberin is a really unique
product and that it offers two different
ways to run the product depending on
what your needs are depending on whether
or not you want to take over operational
responsibilities or if you want to hand
those over to Google and if you provide
any stateless container you can run it
on either platform can you tell us why
cloud run is so important and I know
that you mentioned it at two different
flavors of it can you tell us a little
bit of why cloud world is so important
to developers and a lot of enterprise
customers yeah of course so one of the
pieces of feedback we got with Google
cloud functions was that people wanted
to do serverless but they wanted it
without the restrictions of the
environment so typically with serverless
products cloud functions lambda that
kind of thing you have limitations on
what runtimes are supported because it's
essentially providing a wrapper around
your code and you provide just your
function execution so there's specific
languages that are in use you usually
can't install anything in your
environment if you want dependencies you
have to do a lot of extra work
especially if they're native
dependencies so what we decided was hey
how do we make more things service how
do we make it if you have an existing
app
such as one that does server-side
rendering like Python flask or asp.net
how can you bring that to service
environment and really not have to
rewrite your code entirely use the same
exact tools that you're used to so
that's why we based our product on
container standard OCI containers and
you can essentially provide stateless
because you can't depend on state in
between invitations the other thing
that's unique about the product is that
it will reactivate existing instances so
unlike functions as a service products
where you can only have one instance per
execution here you can set a concurrency
setting so it can be one which would
match the behavior on our functions as a
service platform or you can set it to
something like a tea which means that
you get to reuse those instances similar
to how you would have a traditional
application so it allows you to be a
more efficient with your compute
resources so you mentioned containers do
I have to be an expert in containers to
use this tool no which is great I can
tell you I literally spent an hour
debugging an issue my docker file once
and I personally find it kind of
challenging to use docker files
especially coming from a service
environment now the cool thing is
because OCI containers are a standard
format there's a lot of tools that will
generate a docker container for you so
there's Jim for Java there's Co for go
and then there's also the CM CF build
PACs project which is done by pivotal
and miroku so essentially you get the
really nice experience that you get on a
platform like Heroku where it looks at
your code it figures out what language
you're using and it builds a container
for you and when you use a build pack
that's exactly the experience you get so
you don't even have to author a docker
file if you're not interested in doing
that ok that sounds much much more
approachable than I was imagining
so cloud run is based on containers
rather than functions and the functions
as a service model that Google Cloud
functions in AWS lambda is can we still
count it as serverless yeah that's a
really good question because when lambda
came out you know that was the first
server list product and people started
associating functions as a service with
serverless in fact people said service
was only compute
and you know it has to be you provide
snippet of code and if you do anything
else then that's not service the thing
is that in the community the definition
of server list has evolved so people
talk about surrealist databases people
will talk about something called service
full computing where you're using more
and more managed services rather than
running things yourself like if you use
a machine learning service rather than
training your own model or running a
machine learning workload on a VM so
essentially one way to think about it
when you're running a container is that
you've taken on a little bit more
responsibility you're essentially
deciding what OS packages you want what
the base image you want and what run
time you want to use so that means that
you have to keep your docker file or
whatever you're using up-to-date so
there's a security issue in your
language runtime you are taking on that
responsibility so there's not
necessarily an option that's the best
for everyone it's really a matter of
trade-offs if you need to install custom
packages if you have an existing app
that really doesn't work in a functions
of the service environment then
something like cloud run is a really
good fit if you want to provide just two
snippets of code and have a more of a
managed experience then you can use a
product like Google Cloud functions the
other thing is that you can actually mix
and match so we've put out a open source
JavaScript functions framework and
essentially what that does is it gives
you that same experience that you have
on Google Cloud functions except you can
run it in a container now so you don't
have to choose up front which version
you want to use if you want to have a
functions experience or a container
experience awesome you mentioned there
are sometimes a several trade-offs to
using it I'm curious what are the pros
the best feature set that you can
probably give us about cloud run so the
thing that's really unique is the fact
that you can bring existing applications
there's no other product that offers
that in a server list model you know
there's obviously a lot of products for
running it in a server a full way but if
you want to run server lists you
typically have to re architect your
application the other thing that's
really unique is the fact that you can
reuse instances like I was mentioning so
that means that you have essentially a
very similar execution environment
with the efficiency that you have with
traditional compute except you don't
have to manage the scale out yourself
you don't have to pay for instances when
they're not in use and you can scale to
zero so really you should think of it as
bringing all the benefits of containers
and the flexibility the containers
provide and the tooling that open
tooling that there is for containers
along with the benefits of surplus
gotcha so for any developer that's you
know which is getting started or you
know considering using cloud run how do
you decide whether to use the fully
managed cloud run versus the one that
just runs on gke that's great question
so typically what we found with
customers is as soon as we describe the
two products they know immediately which
product they want to use most customers
as I said want to use the fully managed
product because they don't want to have
the overhead of managing a kubernetes
cluster even if they have the expertise
and if cloud run fully managed meets
your needs then definitely use that
product now there are a lot of customers
especially large enterprises who have
decided to standardize on kubernetes or
they have on-prem installations on
kubernetes that they want to move to the
cloud and for these customers it's a lot
more effective to reuse their existing
cluster and their existing tools and
with these customers are looking for is
an easier developer experience so that
you don't have to be a kubernetes expert
as a developer in order to deploy
applications and typically you know with
these kubernetes clusters since you have
to pre provision your capacity you end
up having spare compute that's not used
so server lives is a great fit for these
applications because it allows you to
scale out as your workload gets more
traffic and then scale back down so
really it's more efficient use of your
existing kubernetes cluster one scenario
for instance that's really resonated
with some customers is as aster recovery
where they have the workload that's
running say in a existing kubernetes
cluster it's taking up some amount of
capacity but if that fails they want to
fail over to another cluster and maybe
the cluster starts out with a very small
size and then they scale up but
essentially you can minimize the amount
of downtime you haven't it minimizes the
amount of spends that you have to use
for some compute capacity that you may
never need just
follow up I know you mentioned that most
of your customers seem to want to shift
from being on prime to fully managed but
what about those that want to stay on
Prem its cloud run still you know a tool
that they can still use yes
so anthos gives you a lot of those
capabilities so there's a few flavors of
anthos anthos is Google's app
modernization platform it's not one
product it's a suite of products and the
idea is that typically geared towards
enterprises but as an enterprise you
have existing investments and you want
to see how to leverage those investments
so if you're running on-premise on
VMware we have a version of cloud run
that runs there so it's a very similar
experience to what you would get on gke
on kubernetes but you get to run it on
your own hardware so we basically have
you know a few levels we have the fully
managed version we're running on
Google's internal compute it actually
runs on google borg if you've heard of
that and google is basically a your ops
team we're obviously going to make some
assumptions on how you want your
platform to run if those assumptions
don't make sense for you then you can
run in kubernetes and take on more
responsibilities but you still have a
more managed experience where you don't
have to think about the actual hardware
and then the apps now if that doesn't
work for you either and you already have
a data center on Prem or somewhere else
and you want to use that existing
investment then you can use cloud run
for anthos deployed on VMware so it's
really up to you which one you want to
use and the API between all these
versions is identical so if you change
your mind you're using the fully managed
cloud run for instance and then your
company says hey please just put that
all on the kubernetes cluster or you're
you know using the fully managed for
your dev mode you can easily move across
environments without rewriting any code
and your config actually mostly will
stay the same so when we talk about all
the cloud run and serverless stuff key
native comes up can you talk a little
bit about key native and its
relationship to cloud run yes so key
native is the API that cloud run is
based on on the fully managed version of
cloud run we don't actually run
kubernetes cluster but we do have
kubernetes api
server so the API that you use to deploy
your application regardless of whether
you're using the fully managed cloud run
or the version that runs on gke is the
Kay native API and that's why we have
this portability between our platforms
and even portability to other vendors so
at Google Cloud Next in April in San
Francisco we had a demo in the keynote
where we deployed an application on the
fully managed for him in the same
application on gke and then we deployed
that as well on IBM's Kay native
offering so because it's all based on
Kay native it's portable and the version
of the service that we run on gke is
essentially the OSS version with some
additional gke specific features added
on top you can move to other vendors and
you can even change your mind and say
hey I I don't want to even deal with
Google's installation I want to do
everything myself I want just Rock a
native you can do that as well so Kay
native is the interaction contract folks
can rely on when using the various cloud
run products exactly so I know that
there's been some Twitter discussions
and changes in our own K native
governments can you tell us a little
more about what's going on and maybe why
some of the decisions that were made
remain yes of course so when we started
the K native project Google was the main
contributor we were coming up with all
of the ideas starting all the working
groups Google was running every single
working group and then as the product
took off it was pretty amazing we
started getting more partners we got I
say P Red Hat pivotal IBM and all these
companies were really eager to
contribute and so we widened the
steering committee to include pivotal
Red Hat and IBM and the feedback that we
heard from both our partners on the
steering committee as well as the
community at large was hey you know
Google isn't the only contributor
anymore now Google is 60% of the
contribution you know why don't we look
at this again why don't we brought in
this base so what we've announced
recently with very positive reaction
from the community is that we're going
to move to a model where based on vendor
contributions and participation which
doesn't have to just include code
contributions it could be other
contributions like design documents
running a working group we want to give
people seats based on that and our goal
is to make it so that Google doesn't
have
60% of ownership anymore is not the 60%
contribution where we have more and more
vendors more and more people taking
leadership positions and ending up with
more diversity in Canada which really
helps everybody in the community both
our partners who are building products
folks who are contributing to K native
or just directly using K native so for
kubernetes for instance I've heard that
Google contributes about 25% now and of
course when it started it was a hundred
percent Google so we'd like to get to a
model like that where we have a very
open model with the community and now
the announcement that we made for the
steering committee is really just the
start some people were like hey this is
really big it was actually by designed
to be big because we didn't want to make
decisions on behalf of the entire
community
so today for instance we hosted and
asked me anything for the steering
committee where people could just ask
questions and talk about what was
important to them for governance so we
plan to do this in the open and talk
about what now what's the algorithm for
deciding seats how do we say when people
can be appointed to the technical
Oversight Committee
let's firm up there are requirements for
being a working group lead and recognize
non code contributions so the goal here
is to be very open and to work together
as community our goal is not to have
this be a Google controlled project that
were the case you know it would have
been a lot easier to just open-source
this and throw it over the wall versus
what we've intended to do which is to
build an open and vibrant community this
community has grown quite large it seems
like and it's safe to say that
surveillance is no longer just a fad so
can you tell us if service is going to
be like the future of cloud computing so
this is a great question my view is that
serverless
is the future of cloud computing it's
going to take a lot of time for people
to move legacy workloads my view is also
that in five or ten years when
serverless does become more dominant
we'll actually see different products
we'll start seeing products where you
can run stateful containers where you
can have more aspects of your
application work in a service manner now
the thing that you know it kind of turns
some people off when they see a platform
like functions of the service is they're
like hey this isn't flexible enough for
me I have existing investments and a lot
of these platforms are geared towards a
hundred percent new development and this
is
a fair point and I think that's where
technologies like cloud or run help and
especially cloud run for anthos that
runs on kubernetes because this means
that you have existing applications you
can leverage those investments so I
think that in the next five to ten years
server lists will become the dominant
matter it kind of will be the default
way about developing applications and
more and more applications will start
taking you dependency we'll have better
ideas of how to deal with existing
applications and modernizing them and
really getting the benefits of the cloud
you know when the cloud came out it was
funny because there's all this marketing
message and the technology didn't really
catch up you know there was this idea of
infinite computer you just write your
application it scales out from all these
machines you know the vendor does
everything for you and of course what
they gave us was essentially
virtualization over hardware right in
the very beginning it was you know the
IT teams job that got easier or not the
application developer and it's taken a
long time but I think we're getting to
the point where now application
developers are really able to leverage
what the cloud provides and to the point
where they're deploying cloud
applications themselves and we're seeing
new tools come up like service framework
plumie that make it a lot easier for
application developers to now take on
some operations responsibilities so this
is an entirely silly question Donna but
this morning a bunch of us were sitting
around talking about the weirdest thing
that we've put in a clock container for
cloud run someone was talking about
Pascal someone was talking about COBOL
so what's the weirdest thing you've seen
someone put in a container and then run
on cloud run so a couple of ones one
that was really funny and I just didn't
expect it would actually work whereas
people took Libre Office which is like a
fork of OpenOffice
it was just like a 16 year old binary
right I mean it's still being actively
developed but you know some of that code
in there is pretty old
and a cloud next when we announce cloud
run we're like hey we're telling you you
can take existing applications and run
them on cloud run let's prove it and you
know the container is huge it's like
over 1 gigabyte has all these
dependencies holy spawns and you can
take that application that's how we had
a PDF Converter the other one that was
interesting was my co-workers really
really into functional languages so he
had an app this is Mike Helmick into the
demo at Google cloud next where he wrote
an app and elixir which I hadn't even
heard of which is a functional language
similar to Erlang and he wrote hangouts
chat integration using them so that
really speaks the power of using
containers yeah you can run COBOL you
know good luck trying around COBOL on
functions of the service platform it's
not going to be fun and of course you're
using COBOL so that's not fun but if you
have these existing applications you
know and maybe you don't want to touch
them because nobody understands how they
work anymore this is very common you
don't have to rewrite your entire app to
make it serverless and that's really the
power what we've offered and that's why
it's really exciting to see the update
somewhere I'm taking from this is cloud
run not just for greenfield projects
this is a totally valid solution for
getting some of that nasty legacy code
that you have in the cloud running in a
scalable way so you're not paying extra
when it's not in use and all that super
cool exactly and you know sometimes
surrealist folks in the community keep
talking about rewriting apps and that
kind of frustrates me because you know
you have an existing app and it's not
broken why would you spend your energy
rewriting that rather than you know
doing something that's going to move
your business forward because your
customers aren't paying you for your
beautiful cloud architecture right
they're paying you for what are you
concretely providing and you know when
Amazon launched like their code it's
like this terrible massive perl scripts
right of course they improve that over
the years but you know customers in
character was Perl scripts yeah I like
the phrase I don't care what the gnomes
in my computer are doing as long as they
return the right answer consistently
exactly
yeah so you mentioned briefly before
that I see is just gonna get so much
easier does that mean that we will see
like IT professionals and Department
starting to wear new hats or less of a
need to hire IT professionals for
applications that scale automatically so
what I think is that IT is still super
important what I've seen among working
with developers who are adopting
serverless applications is that they're
often very operationally naive you know
they have always historically worked in
a model where they're writing their app
and they're throwing it over the wall
and there's some ops team that is
actually deploying it so application
developers are kind of in the dark about
best practices that you know ops teams
have built for years and years and
they've learned through trial and error
you know what works best and what
doesn't so in my discussions with folks
in the DevOps community and folks who
are traditionally coming from an ops
background is that most of them you know
the ones who are interested in up
leveling their skills are really excited
about this change because now with the
cloud becoming more of the forefront ops
is becoming more and more important you
know and it's becoming more democratized
in that regular developers are learning
how to do operations and they're
learning what it's like to be on-call
when I worked at Pulu me developers are
writing employments in a repeatable
manner and they aren't just clicking
around in a console and you know
creating services that they can't
reproduce and they can't redeploy where
you actually have a format that you can
redeploy what we discovered was that
made it so that a lot of folks didn't
need a dedicated person to do ops now of
course you get bigger you need some ops
folks but what's happening is that
developers are now learning and so now
you have this nice collaborative
environment between the dev and ops
folks you no longer have this model
where people are throwing things over
the wall where they're clueless about
how something will work in production
where there's friction between these two
departments and you know the ops folks
are ignored the developers for
destabilizing the system the devs are
pissed off at the ops folks for not
letting them deploy fast enough and now
we're getting into a model where you're
working together you're thinking as a
developer what this means what an outage
means you're thinking about sre skills
or you're working more closely with your
sres
so what I
seeing is that for organizations that
are really eager to learn what the cloud
can offer there's actually a really
really great organizational
transformation that's happening I did a
really quick Google search while you
were answering that question because I
haven't looked at job postings in a
really long time and I was curious to
see if there's going to be positions for
ops engineers and I just searched ops
just as like a general term and sure
enough service came up and then
eventually those postings started
switching to surplus engineers
so I guess to kind of answer my own
question as well I did see now there's
gonna be more of a shift towards hiring
serverless professionals as well as
those who still work in ups yes and in
fact that's a really good point because
one of the first uses for AWS lambda and
still to this day was for operations
tasks so it was things like a virtual
machine has started up in this AWS
account does it have the write
permission doesn't have firewall setup
and if not you know tear down that
machine immediately so those were the
kinds of automation tasks that were very
very popular with AWS lambda and I
personally talked to some ops folks who
are like you know I didn't know how to
use Python I only wrote some bash
scripts but this has been such a useful
way to automate my job so tools like
lambda and serverless aren't just for
developers they're for everybody yeah
one of the talks I gave this summer was
about how don't be afraid of the
serverless and it lets ops folks focus
on the heart and the interesting
problems and make some of the tedium and
boredom which are I sorry team here at
Google calls toil go away and I think
that is so cool and so powerful
absolutely so I think we're running a
little short on time is there anything
that we missed or that you want to
mention you know if the term server list
is scary to you or if you feel like too
hard of a cliff and you you know you
want to stay in the safety of your
existing application you don't need to
be worried don't be scared by folks who
are doing really weird things with AWS
lambda and are like the cutting edge
because you know you're always going to
see people doing the cutting edge stuff
I think service has a lot to offer
existing applications and you don't need
to rewrite your code to leverage these
benefits so there anywhere that you're
going to be if people who listened to
the podcast want to see you out in the
community yes so I'll be speak
at Google cloud next in London and I was
also I did a keynote and a talk at
serverless conf in New York City and
those videos will be available soon so I
recommend checking those out as well as
some of the other speakers there there
were some really interesting talks there
and if folks want to find you online are
you on Twitter or is there a good place
for them to look you up yes I'm on
Twitter at Linda Donna and I post about
all kinds of things including cat photos
well that's going to wrap it up for this
episode of the podcast Donna thank you
for joining us to spend absolute
pleasure
Asha as well and we really hope to hear
of all the great things that service is
going to be doing in the near future
thank you that was so cool clarified a
whole bunch of stuff that I hadn't quite
sorted out for myself so I'm really glad
we got to talk to her and her passion
for that area is so infectious but now
it is time for question of the week
so John I know you've been digging into
open match the open source matchmaking
for games project the bunch of folks are
working on right now can you tell me a
little bit about where I could learn how
to write a matchmaking function for open
match yeah sure
so as of today or yesterday the 0.8
release candidate has been really used
to so on that realist candidate you will
see a lot of notes and getting started
guides on creating a matchmaking
function setting up the director which
will allow you to connect your players
to servers and as well as messing around
with your front-end so the release
candidate has a lot of getting started
guides so to answer your question
specifically about how to write a
matchmaking function what you're going
to do is we have a small template on
what a matchmaking function looks like
you have to file a ticket and then you
pretty much submit a proposal and then
once your proposal is accepted you
returned a match and when you get
returned that match then the director
will connect you to your server and
after you've written this function using
the template or maybe if you want to
play around with it you can alter it as
you like you are going to build and
match make image and then when you push
that image then everything is like
easy-peasy after that you're gonna push
it to your configured registry that you
have associated with your open match
image as well so hopefully that's not
too overwhelming and hopefully our
guides get you started and hopefully you
have some fun with it and if folks are
running into trouble is there a way that
they can give y'all feedback on that so
you can reach out to the open match
twitter we take a lot of questions there
you can ping me directly
syntax error one on Twitter and you can
also join our Open match community if
you like I will post a link to our slack
and you know we're always looking
forward to having new members new
contributors or just people with general
feedback that is so cool so you're gonna
be anywhere anytime soon
I think everyone's doing a bit of travel
come down yeah I have a bunch of travel
coming up I'm going to be an enemy NYC's
gonna be pretty fun afterwards I'm going
to a wedding in Maryland all my friends
and family decided to get married this
year so whole bunch of weddings a whole
bunch of suits and a lot of ties and
after that I'll be going to cute con
which should be really fun we're we're
running the gun is an open match
workshop nice
now you're talking and that'll be from
the 18th until the 22nd I believe in San
Diego and to round things up from my
year I'll probably be messing around and
traveling to Kirkland to meet with the
ng team for open match wow that's a lot
of trouble so while you're keep going
I'm actually gonna be at GCP next London
talking about cloud run I'm gonna be
moderating a panel in the dead zone and
also just hanging out we're stopping
booth checking out people all hot
stickers if you like dinosaur stickers
come find me I'll give you a dinosaur
stickers and that is November 20th and
the 21st at the Excel Centre in London
after that I am unclear I thought I had
plans and then they got confused so I
will let everyone know on my next
episode of the podcast where I'll be
after that that's awesome I wish I could
go to next London I do enjoy going to
London quite a bit now some really good
friends that are GT e--'s that are
probably attending as well so very
jealous it should be a good time so I
think that's all we got for this week
thanks y'all for listening I just want
to thank our listeners for tuning in
another week and we'll look forward to
see you next week
[Music]
you